pour faire le point sur la situation en
ukraine après 100 jours de conflit
j'accueille autour de cette table galia
ackerman bonsoir fidèles de l'émission
historienne spécialiste de la russie
post soviétique
annie de menton bonsoir vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste de l'ukraine
vous connaissez d'autant mieux le crâne
que vous y avez vécu puisque vous avez
été c'est vrai voilà à kiev conseillère
culturelle à l'ambassade de france
christian lequesne pour soir bonsoir
vous êtes professeur à sciences po paris
j'accueille aussi par écran interposé
olivier dorgans vous êtes avocat et
spécialiste des sanctions soir
bonsoir et puis bien sûr laeticia qui
restent avec moi tout au long de
l'émission avant de commencer je
voudrais d'abord vous demandez à chacun
ce qui vous a le plus surpris ou le plus
marqué pendant ses cent jours de conflit
a dit de rentrer on commence avec vous
m'écoutez puisque vous avez parlé de
surprise finalement ça a été a des
sentiments les plus marquants et les
plus forts c'est à dire la violence la
force et la surprise des premiers jours
et ensuite il ya eu la découverte des
horreurs
de boue de chahir pierre moreau janka
est donc ça a été les deux fêtes
après lesquels on a compris la gravité
du conflit dans lequel nous étions
engagés et qui nous concerne l'ukraine
et la russie mais un conflit qui rebat
toutes les cartes de la géopolitique
bien sûr on dit à nos jours bien sûr et
ça on en avait peut-être pas conscience
véritablement au début au début c'était
quand même quelque chose de relativement
localisée en plus galia ackerman le sait
bien on a travaillé depuis 2014 sur le
conflit entre la russie et l'ukraine
donc ce n'était pas quelque chose de
nouveau pour nous mais mais là il y
avait effectivement en germe oui bien
sûr une dimension beaucoup plus lâches
qui pouvait advenir mais qui n'était pas
encore en tout cas tout à fait clair et
ce week-end qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
vous pendant ses cent jours de conflit
deux choses m'ont frappé la première
c'est la résistance du peuple ukrainien
je crois que nous avions tous la grande
peur
lorsque nous avons appris l'intervention
militaire le 24 février que le rouleau
compresseur de l'armée russe allait
anéantir rapidement ce pays
sans que les ukrainiens puisse résister
or ce n'est pas du tout ce qui s'est
passé donc c'est le premier élément de
surprise le deuxième élément de surprise
c'est l'existence en ukraine pour
organiser cette résistance d'un état
quand même et cet état incarné par ce
président de la république on aurait pu
penser que le système politique était le
système politique d'un état failli or ce
n'est pas du tout ce que nous ce que
nous observons donc ce sont vraiment de
surprise pour moi tôt j'allais dire
positive aussi intense et en malaisie
dont comme vous le dites une
configuration qui est quand même marqué
beaucoup par le malheur la mort comme
hélas dans toutes les guerres gary
ackerman qu'est ce qui vous a marqué
vous pendant ses cent jours
en plus de ce qu'a déjà a dit à une
question
qui sont des sentiments que je partage
pleinement ce qui m'a marqué
personnellement vous savez je me suis
beaucoup occupé à étudier l'histoire de
la seconde guerre mondiale et ce qui m'a
surpris c'est à quel point ce que font
les russes actuellement rappelle d'une
part le comportement
des armées allemandes lors de
l'occupation de la même trend et le
comportement de l'armée soviétique qui a
repris donc le cren y compris les
territoires de l'ukraine occidentale qui
ont été pour la première fois un excès
en vertu du pacte molotov ribbentrop et
on a pu voir exactement les mêmes
procédés dans les territoires occupés
aujourd'hui comme si les dirigeants
russes d'aujourd'hui les dirigeants
militaires d'aujourd'hui avait suivi
un manuel jadis écrit
céline disait à l'époque que l'ukraine
avait été puni deux fois par les
allemands et par les russes absolument
c'est les déportations de la population
civile les déportations forcées
c'est le pillage institutionnalisé parce
qu'il ya le pillage personnel de deux
militaires mais aussi le pillage des
usines entières de d'industrie entière
et setra
les arrestations les listes des
activistes l'idée qu'il faut rééduquer
des nazis fier de ses trains bondés
nazifié et rééduquer c'est à peu près
pareil
enlèvement d enfant
qu'on donne aux familles russes
la volonté d'inclure ces populations
occupées donc dans l'effort productif si
j'ose dire de la russie a notamment les
obliger contre la nourriture de déblayer
ce que les russes ont détruit donc tout
ça que qui suivent à ce point à ce point
les scénarii vieux de 80 ans c'est quand
même étonnant y compris le le drapeau de
la victoire c'est à dire tout simplement
le drapeau rouge avec faucille et
marteau est là et le rétablissement de
statues de lénine dans les villes et
villages occupés
c'était absolument
gigantesque retour en arrière bolliger
dorgans je vous pose la même question
qu'est ce qui vous a marqué vous en
cessant jour
pour moi ce qui m'a marqué et en deux
temps c'est d'une part la rapidité de la
réponse des pays occidentaux qui ont
vraiment des filles définitivement
choisi d'utiliser un instrument dont on
parle est finalement très peu jusqu'à
jusqu'au début de la guerre qui est
l'instrument des sanctions économiques
qui a été qui a eu une adoption
absolument incroyable d'armes de
célérité et de secteurs visés très
rapidement on a vu la commission et les
états membres qui fonctionne de
l'unanimité sur ce type d'instrument
juridique travaillé jour et nuit est
publié chaque semaine des nouveaux
textes qui commencent à s'empiler qui
crée une certaine fatigue et ce qui me
surprend aujourd'hui sans trop me
surprendre paradoxalement c'est le fait
qu'on commence à voir les premières
files de cette unité européenne on le
voit depuis le début du début du mois de
mai on avait une forme de cohésion dans
la proche de cet instrument et où nous
avions
vraiment clairement quelque chose qui me
surprend aussi dans dans cette élection
au final un service très rapidement pour
rebondir ce que vous disiez que si dans
le kent c'est la capacité totalement
inattendue de volodymyr et linski
d'incarner cette résistance ukrainienne
joue rappelle que c'est un acteur
ultra-populaire homme de télé producteur
de télé on n'avait aucune idée de la
façon dont ils seraient capables déjà
même de gouverner d'ukraine sans même un
état de guerre donc vous imaginez bien
le peuple ukrainien face à ce nouveau
président très très conforme à l'époque
finalement un président qui n'a aucun
passé politique qui se retrouve à devoir
faire face à vladimir poutine et à
donner confiance en son peuple pour
lutter contre les militaires russes et
ça pour moi c'est la plus grande
surprise deux côté ukrainien bien sûr de
cette guerre ce sont les circonstances
qui font le courage et les grandes
femmes ou les deux hommes on va faire un
point sur la situation dans quel état
c'est possible de former cette question
ainsi et la population ukrainienne
aujourd'hui annie de menton
c'était compliqué pour elle parce que
c'est vrai qu'en début de conflit il ya
toujours une sorte d'énergie dans la
dans la réalité immédiate et leur chance
immense problème qu'il faut qu'il faut
régler là maintenant je pense qu'il ya
une sorte de petite dépression après
cela je voudrais dire une petite chose
par rapport à ce que disait question le
kent et et vous même sur la force de la
démocratie ukrainienne
c'est vrai que le président est mince
qui s'est montrée remarquable mais il
faut pas oublier que ce pays est
terriblement décentralisée et que tout
il ya eu des sentinelles démocratique
qui se sont allumés dans tout le pays et
se sont tous les responsables régionaux
qui d'ailleurs ont été immédiatement
ciblé par moscou parce que voyant qu'il
ne pouvait pas attraper kiev s'était
quand même pas mal d'essayer de
décapiter le pays par l'intermédiaire de
ses voix souvent ce gouvernement
intervenir
ils font si je puis dire ils font leur
show aussi c'est à dire qu'ils ont
appris comme celle un ski que voilà il
faut se pas se vendre mais valoriser son
travail communiqué et donc ce sont des
relais absolument remarquable et du coup
ils font ce lien avec la population
qu'on appelle de façon un peu rhétorique
société civile mais qui s'est montrée la
véritablement dans cette capacité parce
que elle a eu le vernis démocratique sur
les épaules ce sont des gens qui ont
voté pour ces gouverneurs pour serrer
ses mères ces responsables régionaux et
donc qu'il ya cette vie démocratique
cette envie certains gouverneurs qui
disent écoutez je sais pas comment faire
mais je vais m'appuyer sur la convention
de genève et à partir de là on verra
d'ailleurs souvent cdte est
intellectuellement souvent des têtes
bien faites parfois des gens de terrain
un peu importe mais souvent qu'ils ont
ce background pour réagir face à ces
événements en s'appuyant sur des textes
des choses qui nous paraissent
quelquefois un peu absurde par rapport à
l'urgence de situation
germann si on fait un point sur la
situation militaire j'allais dire c'est
que vladimir poutine a revu sa stratégie
pendant cette période de son jour
comment vous qualifieriez la situation
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on est dans une
guerre de position est ce que ça peut
s'accélérer est-ce qu'on est dans une
période un peu joli nom n'est sûrement
pas dans une période je l'est parce que
les russes ont complètement changé leur
tactique ils ont essayé d'attaquer sur
tous les fronts simultanément ce qui
bien sûr était absurde d'un point de vue
militaire
maintenant ils utilisent la tactique
classique d'ailleurs même là il
s'inspire beaucoup de la seconde guerre
mondiale et de la doxa qui en résultent
parce que c'est ce qui a été toujours
enseigné dans les académies militaires
soviétiques et russes et donc maintenant
il se concentre sur quelques régions
c'est à dire surtout le d'une basse
qu'elle sonne a été occupé dans les
premiers jours ils ont aussi réussi à
occuper une partie des apories gien et
donc c'est le rouleau compresseur qui
continue à avancer
lentement et de descendre bas mais
absolument péniblement mais qui continue
et je pense que si les ukrainiens
n'obtiennent pas très rapidement
par exemple et les installations les
lance
roquettes multiples ce que les
américains ont déjà promis qu'ils
permettent attirer bon les américains
n'ont pas voulu donner
les installations et les missiles qui
peuvent tirer jusqu'à 300 km mais même
s'il donne ce qui tire à 80 kilomètres
ça peut changer la donne parce que
aujourd'hui
comme vous savez le
ciel donc n'est pas couvert
les ce sont des steppes tout tout tout
tout ce qu'ils font est à nu même s'il
ya des tranchées parce que c'est visible
depuis les airs
et donc il faut que les ukrainiens et
maintenant
des avantages
en armement et leur permettre de
repousser les russes pourquoi c'est très
important je dis juste une chose dans
les médias russes parmi les officiels
russes on parle beaucoup de l'annexion
d'une basse deux personnes et donc au
moins d'une partie des impôts rien on
donne déjà la date ça pourrait se faire
en juillet c'est à dire d'ici un mois un
mois et demi tout c'est un objectif de
guerre c'est pas l'objectif final de la
guerre mais ça nourrit ses grands
objectifs de guerre et je vous dirais qu
est-ce qui va faire la différence
si la russie un excès territoire selon
sa propre loin ça va être le territoire
russe qu'ils sont obligés de défendre et
donc chaque tir chaque but qui va tomber
sur ce territoire ça va être perçu comme
une agression comme une agression et là
la fameuse menace de vladimir poutine
d'utiliser le nucléaire devient un peu
plus probable que jusqu'à maintenant
donc il est très important que les
ukrainiens pis riposté très rapidement
justement gadea qui a même parlé de
livraisons d'armes l'occident a promis
beaucoup alors il y aura quand même
qu'ils sont arrivés et qu'ils qui
augmente c'est de l'argent et des armes
que ce soit de la part des états unis où
l'offre ça peut changer la donne
christian lequesne mais ça change et la
tonne de la résistance ukrainienne
depuis le début s'il n'y avait pas eu
les livraisons d'armes occidentale
américaine bien sûr mais aussi
européennes l'armée ukrainienne n'aurait
pas eu cette capacité de résistance à
l'invasion russe et ça ça continue on
vient de parler de l'importance d'avoir
ses lance-roquettes
à portée de 300 kilomètres américains
les allemands ont fait savoir qu'ils
allaient livrer un système extrêmement
perfectionnés de défense aérienne madame
colonna
la ministre française des affaires
étrangères était
en ukraine et a dit aussi qu'il y aurait
des livraisons dans quelques semaines
d'armé n'a pas elle n'a pas précisé les
enfants on sait que la france a
livré eu déjà des canons automoteurs les
fameux césar à l'ukraine donc tout ça
est extrêmement important et d'ailleurs
il ya un effet domino sur
la prise en compte de la défense comme
un élément important aujourd'hui des
politiques publiques et je crois que la
meilleure manifestation ça a été le
référendum danois qui a eu lieu hier 60
pour la première fois exactement 30 ans
d'exemption de politique européenne de
défense des référents d'un négatif on se
rappelle du référendum négatif de 1992
le danemark à 67% à voter pour la
réintégration du pays dans la politique
est ce que ça va changer pour l'europe
de la défense on sait que déjà
l'allemagne a fait sont une sorte
d'agent drame d'un jean d'un manteau
avec avec ce conflit en termes de budget
pour son armée à elle qu'est ce que ça
change le
ça change le fait que politiquement
vous avez une cohésion qui
peut se faire au niveau des partenaires
européens plus importante et puis une
incitation aussi à dépenser plus
d'ailleurs les responsables politiques
danois la première ministre social
démocrate a tout de suite fait savoir
que le danemark avait comme objectif
d'atteindre les fameux 2% vous savez du
pipe consacré à l'armement qui est une
des recommandations de l'otan alors on
puisqu'on parle d'europe
lundi l'union européenne a à côté adopté
en tout cas un nouveau paquet sens de
sanctions c'est le sixième ils
concernent notamment le pétrole dont on
va réduire les importations de 2 90%
olivier doran c'est ce qu'on peut
mesurer l'impact à venir de ces
sanctions et déjà faire un petit point
sur celles qui ont qui ont été prises
alors les sanctions qui ont été prises
dans un premier temps sont des sanctions
qui sont venus clairement aux visées des
secteurs qui seraient les membres
impactant d'emprunter économique pour
l'économie européenne donc secteur
financier russe on a dû progressivement
des sanctions être ensuite être imposée
sur l'acier sur le charbon sur le
transport depuis ou vers la russie et la
de la question l'énergie est au coeur
des débats européens depuis maintenant
un petit peu plus de deux mois des
sommets de versailles et la fin du mois
de mars on a décidé de réduire notre
dépendance énergétique au gaz au niveau
européen des deux tiers d'ici à la fin
d'année même si à l'heure où je vous
parle il n'y a pas encore des actions
très concrètes qui ont été prises en ce
sens et la question du nom margot sur
pétrole est sur la table depuis depuis
quasiment le tout début de ces sanctions
avec une forte résistance de pays dont
notamment l'anglais qui d'une part sont
très dépendants du pétrole russe parce
que ils n'ont pas accès au maire et donc
ils sont obligés de faire venir par le
gazoduc
toute une série de par l'oléoduc
pardonne par dalmat et toute une touche
une grande partie de leurs importations
de pétrole et on a vu dans ce front
européen qui était relativement
sûre les 4 ou les cinq premiers trains
de sanctions c'est rodez autour de la
question d'énergie avec une crainte
également devoir comme j'ai pu le faire
la russie au moment par exemple des
référendums
en matière de en matière d'adhésion a le
temps de voir la russie menacé de couper
le gaz et donc on ne sait pas d'ailleurs
ce qui se passera ce lundi s'il faut
bien pressé il faut bien préciser pardon
pour le téléspectateur que le paquet de
sanctions ils concernent les
importations de pétrole mais pas
toujours grâce pour l'instant parce que
les européens ont pas ont pas su se
mettre d'accord on sait que leurs
économies sont pas exposés de la même
manière au gaz russe
exactement effectivement pas se gâte
pour cette raison et puis également pas
de show gaz pour des raisons qui sont
beaucoup plus pragmatique de capacité un
poids à trouver des canaux alternatifs
pour pour le gaz savoir que le transport
du gaz étant de transport qui est
beaucoup plus complexe que le transport
du pétrole dans lequel l'europe a par
ailleurs investi énormément d'argent
notamment en créant d unité de
regazéification pour importer du gaz
naturel liquéfié et donc la question
d'une transition d'une privation
complète du gaz russe est difficilement
sur la table d'un point de vue purement
pragmatique mais s'il ne serait très
compliqué pour lille pour l'europe de
trouver dans un temps très court délai
pour remplacer complètement
l'importation baisse qui effectivement
représente presque la moitié de notre
notre dépendants de nos importations en
matière de gaz galea karman ces
sanctions elles se font ressentir en
russie sur l'économie russe sur la
population russe très certainement pour
l'instant l'impact n'est pas encore très
important pour la vie quotidienne mais
il est présent il ya beaucoup de
produits qui ont disparu de supermarché
il ya beaucoup de grandes chaînes de
magasins ou de chaînes de production qui
ont été fermées en vendant notamment les
actifs des sociétés russes je vous cite
par exemple
le la chaîne qui a été l'une des
premières à être présentes en russie
post communiste qui a été immensément
populaire c'est le mcdonald's est
donc maintenant c'est s'est revendu
c'est pas l'asphyxient de l'économie
russe pas encore mais il ya beaucoup de
choses où la réussite dépend presque
entièrement des importations et donc on
pense que d'ici un mois deux mois trois
mois grand maximum les avions russes par
exemple ne pourront plus voler tout
simplement parce que il n'y aura pas de
pièces détachées non mon actif aux en
voilà ça va frapper aussi très durement
le complexe militaro industriel
parce que là aussi à des composantes
électroniques il ya toutes sortes de
choses qui sont importés et qui ne le
seront plus et donc les virus les
officiels russes parlent tout le temps
des deux du remplacement des
importations il ya un terme aux russes
spécial importe aux machines donc le
problème avec avec ce remplacement c'est
que ils ont trouvé maintenant une parade
en
souhaitant un donc emporté vers la
russie des
des objets on peut dire
pas par des canaux officiels disons par
exemple les voitures et à des
concessionnaires vous achetez chez opel
ou chez volkswagen et ses trains
maintenant ils vont acheter auprès des
tiers qui est qui qui serviront de
revendeurs
d'une part je pense que c'est une parade
qui sera assez difficile il ya toute une
liste maintenant publié par les ministre
russe dd donc d'exister que ça peut pas
tenir
ça va finir par produire un effet
cataclysmique pour les curieux même si
l'on n'est pas encore scellé donc même
avec tous ces schémas ce qu'on appelle
des schémas gris un compte et il y aura
des choses qui seront importés n'ont pas
illégalement mais par par des pl par des
institutions donc d'intermédiaire d'une
part je pense qu'il sera très facile aux
pays occidentaux de retrouver ces
filières et de l'est cessé de
fonctionner et en plus il ya un énorme
risque de pièces détachées contrefaites
parce que oui qui peut là pour le coup
elle avait questions d'armement ou
l'édition de ce tragique et donc pour
remplacer tout ce qu'ils ne pourront pas
importée il faut des efforts de
plusieurs années c'est pas c'est pas une
blague c'est pas aujourd'hui on ne livre
plus on va faire ça va prendre du temps
et olivier d'orience juste rapidement ça
déjà ça a déjà marché les sanctions pour
mettre à genoux un pays et une force et
c'est une question qui est très très
compliqué parce que les sanctions comme
vous le disait très justement
s'inscrivent dans une temporalité qui
est beaucoup plus longue que les
événements qu'elle vienne le sanctionner
et donc là on a on commente quasiment
quotidiennement l'évolution militaire on
commente les progrès diplomatique
l'absence de problèmes diplomatiques et
parallèlement on a beau texte je les
note qui commence à faire effet mais
c'est le temps politique est très long
ses premiers points 2e pensé qu' il est
très difficile de finale des éléments
objectifs parce que pourrait finalement
sur par exemple la santé l'économie
russe il faut qu' on est des chiffres
qui sont des chiffres qu'on sait déjà
être des civils qui seront possiblement
des chiffres pas forcément compétents la
réalité puisqu'ils seront publiés par la
banque centrale russe n'a donc oui les
sanctions fonctionne en termes d'impact
sur l'économie après on a sur des
idéologies on met sur une guerre
idéologique au sien aussi et donc de
fait quand bien même l'économie
souffrira de ces sanctions souffre des
aristocrates sanction est ce que ce sera
suffisant pour faire plier les velléités
expansionnistes de la nuit un petit je
pense que la réponse est très compliqué
à avoir parce qu'on est une idéologie on
est aussi sur une psychologie
christian lequesne qu'est ce que vous
avez appris de vladimir poutine pense
toujours
écouté j'ai j'ai appris que d'abord nous
avions affaire à quelqu'un qui
est un dictateur très très clairement
c'est à dire qui ne qui ne croient pas
dans les vertus de la démocratie qui
préfère qu'ils préfèrent clairement la
violence et l'or ça vous le saviez déjà
on le savait déjà mais ça a été confirmé
et puis je crois mais bon vous savez
c'est toujours très difficile de saisir
la psychologie des dictateurs je le
croyais dans le fond quand même plus
rationnel qui ne l'a été
c'est à dire que là on voit clairement
qu'ils n'hésitent pas à envoyer au casse
pipe pour parler vulgairement les
soldats les soldats russes on parle
quand même de 30000 morts l'afghanistan
c'était bon je regardais justement le 12
11 milliards dont
l'idéologie ch cet homme est finalement
ce qui ce qui domine et
je crois que tout ça s'appuie très
largement sur une reconstruction de
l'histoire
voilà il le pour moi le le discours
essentiel c'est le discours du 21
février ou avant la tacc voilà
exactement où ils nous il nous refait
toute l'histoire de l'ukraine et de
l'union soviétique
c'est effrayant d'ailleurs ce qui change
pas non plus et c'est le cynisme chez
vladimir poutine laetitia krupa
la propagande russe en avait vu après la
mort du journaliste de bfm tv frédéric
leclerc imhof de nouveau la propagande
russe s'est mise en oeuvre on commence à
en avoir l'habitude vous avez raison et
la propagande russe a embrayé très vite
c'est l' agence de presse officielle tap
que l'on connaît désormais ici en france
elle affirmé tout simplement que
frédéric leclerc imhoff et est un
mercenaire engagés dans la livraison
d'armes aux forces l'ukrainienne voilà
je rappelle quand même que nous sommes
aussi dans un contexte communicationnel
très particulier en russie
le mot guerre n'est toujours pas
employer mathieu et si on l'utilisent on
peut être emprisonné mais la mère de
frédéric avait tenu à répondre a voulu
pourtant répondre à la longue elle a
répondu quasiment immédiatement le
lendemain elle a envoyé un communiqué où
elle dit que malgré la douleur elle
c'est pourquoi son fils est mort bien
sûr pour la liberté pour le droit
d'informer sur cette guerre en ukraine
et puis dans ce communiqué elle
s'adresse directement à l'agent stas
avec ces mots je suis la maman du jeune
journaliste que vous avez tué hier votre
communiqué me donne la nausée bien sûr
vous cherchez lâchement à vous dédouaner
mais sachez que jamais vous ne réussirez
à salir sa mémoire et emmanuel macron
lui aussi intervenu pour condamner la
propagande russe quelques heures après
le communiqué de la mer de frédéric
leclerc imhof le chef de l'état français
en marge du sommet européen de bruxelles
a tenu à faire entendre la parole
officielle de la france après l'amour de
notre confrères de bfm tv
également avec la plus grande fermeté
les premiers propos que j'ai entendu
d'officiel remettant en cause le statut
de journaliste votre collègue vous sa
présence sur le terrain ça c'est
inacceptable donc il ya un cadre qui
existent les journalistes les
humanitaires doivent être protégés sur
les lieux de guerre les civils devraient
être protégés sur le vulgaire et on le
voit bien aujourd'hui la guerre qu'a
choisi de mener la russie compte revient
à tous le droit international on entend
un c'est maud emmanuel macron l'a répété
depuis le départ bien sûr qu'en
parallèle de la guerre militaire il ya
cette guerre d'information de
communication emmanuel macron vise dans
ses propos les officiels russes et non
pas vladimir poutine est factuellement
c'est vrai que ces accusations de
mercenaires viennent d'un officier des
forces séparatistes pro-russes juste
pour finir mathieu le parquet national
anti terroriste s'est saisi dès lundi
soir et a annoncé lundi soir donc
l'ouverture d'une enquête pour crimes de
guerre annie dont on compare les deux
mamelles macron les relations entre mm
macro et volodymyr services qui y sont
plutôt fraîches en tout cas changeantes
elles sont très fraîches elles sont très
très fraîche et c'est sûrement ce que
reproche le président n'a pas encore
fait ce qu'il fallait pour se rattraper
si je puis dire c'est à dire écoutez il
a c'est vrai que depuis le début de ce
conflit là ce rapport avec
celui qu'il appelle cher vladimir qui
est quand même un tout petit peu ambiguë
avec ses ces conversations
unilatérale parce qu'on ne voit pas très
bien ce qu'il peut arriver à faire
passer ses complaisances
de propos où il ya des mots de la
propagande qui sont repris la guerre
fraternelle ne pas humilier la russie il
ya des choses qui passent vraiment très
mal et qui manque en plus de
d'engagement vis-à-vis de du côté
ukrainien ou si vous voulez jouer les go
between ce qui serait absolument un
travail fondamental dans la situation
actuelle il faudrait au moins que les le
canal soit ouvert des deux côtés c'est
pas tout à fait le cas en ce moment et
sans vainqueur à juin oui je pense que
dans le contexte européen il ya aussi
les maladresses de monsieur de monsieur
macro et en particulier la manière dont
il a annoncé dans son discours
à strasbourg ce projet de communauté
politique européenne je ne dis pas que
le projet en soi est un mauvais projet
mais c'est un projet
téléspectateurs plutôt qu'une adhésion à
l'union européenne
salle d'attenté
ne doit pas devenir un purgatoire enfin
on l'espère
non il a il a dit ça prendra des
décennies et c'est intéressant parce que
c'est une espèce de constante chez les
chez les hommes politiques français dès
lors qu'on parle d'élargissement de
l'union européenne ya un espèce
d'affolement et c'est un affolement
aussi de la machine politico
administratives françaises d'ailleurs
des conseillers du président et on avait
exactement la même chose à l'égard de
l'europe centrale alors je ne suis pas
en train de dire que l'ukraine doit
entrer deux mains dans l'union
européenne bien entendu ce n'est pas
possible mais il faut valoriser les
points positifs de cette demande
d'adhésion et les points positifs c'est
le fait que l'ukraine veut se rapprocher
des valeurs de l'europe pour échapper
justement à l'imposition des bad est
d'aider des normes
de monsieur de monsieur poutine et il
faut comprendre aussi c'est un point g
insiste là-dessus parce qu'en france on
a beaucoup de mal il faut comprendre
qu'avec la fin de la guerre froide
le projet de l'intégration européenne
est aussi devenu un projet de gestion
des marges et si nous ne gérons pas les
marges de l'europe et bien d'autres
s'emparent on émarge de l'europe et ça
c'est vrai à la fois dynamique et être
jusqu'à et pour les balkans occidentaux
de la même manière d'un point de vue
économique et d'un point de vue
géopolitique c'est bien évidemment ce
que vous vous dire merci christian
lequesne